I'm Jennie Kim. I'm of Korean descent. And I experience alcohol flush reaction.
>> Well, for those of us, like me, who have not
experienced the alcohol flush reaction. Can you describe it for us?
>> Basically, I get really warm. And
I turn bright red whenever I drink alcohol.
>> I see. do you. Is it associated with any feelings of being sick?
I get a little bit queasy. I don't tolerate alcohol very well. And I
really can't drink more than a couple of drinks at a time.
>> I see, so your tolerance then is maybe a little
bit lower than other people of your same height and size.
>> Exactly.
>> Now is this something that's common in your family?
>> It is. my dad also experienced alcohol flush
reaction, and he. Really doesn't drink, as a result.
>> Now, when did you first realize that you had this kind of alcohol flush?
>> It's kind of a funny story. my mom was
looking through my Facebook party pictures, back when I was
in college. And one day, she just sort of asked,
she was looking through them. Looked up at me and
said, why are you so sunburned in all your pictures?
>>
[LAUGH].
>> And that's when I realized something was up. Yeah. My mom
didn't, didn't understand. Because she herself
does not have alcohol flush reaction.
>> I see. Now, does this mean that you have any personal
genetic information about your, yourself or
your family for this particular trait?
>> Yes. We've all We've all used 23andMe.
>> You have, and what was your
report for the ALDH2, the aldahyde dehydrogenase enzyme.
>> If I can
remember correctly my father and I only have one working copy of that gene.
>> I see. So you're heterozygous?
>> Yes.
>> So, wow that means you, well we don't know
who you inherited it from unless we know, is your
mom. You said you mom does not have this? I
see, so you know that you inherited this from your dad.
>> Definitely from my dad, yeah.
>> Wow. How does that make you feel?
>> I don't know, just
>>
[LAUGH]
>> Empathetic I guess, for my dad.
>>
[LAUGH]
do you consider this I guess a good or a
bad trait at all? Or a positive or a negative thing?
>> Well it's funny that you ask that, you know?
I think if you'd asked me this in col, back
in college, I would have said it's definitely a negative
thing. I wish I didn't have it Then I could, you
know, have champagne all the time and it would be
awesome. But now I'm actually pretty grateful for it. First
of all, it's good I think that it helps me
be more aware of the impact alcohol has on my body.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Which is
generally a good thing for my health and well-being. and second
I actually kind of like, or at least appreciate strangely enough
how that this reaction is somewhat socially embarrassing and awkward. I
actually appreciate feeling bad about myself
sometimes. Because that's why I'm funny.
>> And you raise an interesting point
there. You know, as someone who experiences
alcohol flush reaction. And let's say someone
watching this class maybe is only just discovering
this for themselves. Is it an embarrassing feeling or do
like people ever like, make fun of you for it or?
>> Well you know I think
back when I started noticing it, I was
much more self-conscious. I like to think though
that really that people are too self-involved to
really notice other people. At least I am.
>>
[LAUGH]
>> So I, you know, I, I've become a lot more
comfortable with that. And I also just don't care as much.
>> Yeah, so obviously the disadvantages of
alcohol flush reaction are that you can feel
kind of bad, you don't have that high of a tolerance, and there may be some
kind of awkward social stuff occasionally. Are
there any advantages besides the ones you mentioned
about, you know being more self-aware about yourself,
is there any kind of other advantage to?
>> I actually like the fact that it moderates. It forces me to moderate
my drinking. And be pretty judicious about
drinking. I always have to ask myself, like,
is this cocktail really worth it? I have a saying that I can either be
drinking or I can be cute. But I can't be both at the same time.
>>
[LAUGH]
>> So I'll often just choose to be cute. And you know just
choose not to participate in alcohol at all. and as I'm getting older,
I kind of appreciate that more to have that choice. And I feel
better, you know, in the mornings than maybe some of my other friends would.
>> What about any kind of medication?
You know, for lactose intolerance and people who
actually, whose bodies don't metabolize lactose very
easily, they can actually take a bio-active form.
Of lactase, which allows them to digest dairy products. Is there
anything like that for alcohol flush reaction that you know of?
>> There's kind of this over the counter remedy that a lot of my Asian peers
and I have discovered. It's just an over
the counter antacid or acid reducing pill which
I used to call the anti-Asian pill. and I used to take that when I drank.
But, later I found out that research shows
that it actually isn't good for you to suppress
your bodies symptoms as it processes this toxin. so I stopped taking it.